what's up gang I had to jump right back
here in studio we couldn't wait till
Monday on the shop show to break down
all this real housewives of the UFC
drama going down if you haven't heard
and it's all over Jon Jones is out of
his title fight at Mat Square Garden
with Stipe it is out it's not happening
Jon Jones tore his peack and I don't
mean like a slight tear they're saying
he tore his peack off the bone if you
know anything about these injuries which
I do I've had Peck issues I've had many
of friends who were professional
athletes who have torn their Peck and
when it's completely torn off the bone
this is not a fast turnaround time uh
the UFC said minimum eight months
minimum that's uh assuming he has
surgery they got to open up they got to
reattach that muscle to the Bone there's
a lot that goes into a torn PEC so I
assume he's out probably a year Jon
Jones probably isn't fighting for a year
he's not getting any younger and also
um UFC missed the boat on this a little
bit not uh stripping I guess he you I
guess yeah stripping him up the belt uh
when he beat sarl Gan he's the
heavyweight champ when you're champed
out at least a year with this injury um
there should not be a inter term title
fight that it should just be the vacant
belt um when you think about Jon Jones
and
stepe the I guess the rumor anybody
who's close to the game knows that the
plan was for both these guys to retire
um so whether it was win or loss on
either end um steep Bay I think was
playing on retiring Jon Jones was going
to do the same thing so either way even
if their fight were to go down like it
was supposed to in two weeks you still
don't really have a heavyweight champion
the UFC knows this we all know this so
they announced Tom Aspen versus Sergey
pavlovich and it's for an interterm
heavyweight title that doesn't make any
sense in any facet because even if JN
wasn't going to retire or even if the
fight went on you weren't going to have
a true heavyweight champ so you get
Sergey and Tom Asen all fighting for
intern belt that makes no freaking sense
that should be just for the straight up
vacant World title fight so we know it's
going to go down like that and it
definitely should so let's talk about
Aspen versus Sergey
pavlovich there's a thing going on right
now especially lately and it's a
blessing and a curse the blessing is as
a fight fan which we are if you're
watching this and if you're in the game
you like the game these big fights fall
out the UFC this is the reason the
biggest boxing would never do this where
a main event pulls out a championship
fight pulls out and they replace that
fighter with even bigger name or a
bigger fight or at least complim
complimentary to it it's a massive fight
either way because Matt Square Garden's
a big card they're not just going to put
in two Schmucks in there you're getting
big names like Sergey and Tom aspinal so
it's all good on the fight side we love
this as a fighter though it kind of
sucks because you're getting the biggest
opportunity of your life and you're on a
two-e notice for Alex volkanovski was a
10-day notice um it's not ideal for
those guys also as a consumer you just
see the names like oh this can be so
dope you're right but the problem is is
you're getting a watered down version so
you're not getting the elite of the
elite at their complete 100% effort
because they're only getting two we
camps
so again it's a blessing and curse the
blessing is heck yeah UFC do your thing
the replacement with these massive
fights and I'm all for it the downside
is you're not getting the best out of
both Fighters that being said Tom Absol
Sergey pavlovich two weeks take my money
I'll watch them fight every Saturday if
I could I'm so high on Tom Aspen all I
think this fight's not even close if Tom
has a 12we camp if his 12we Camp uh Tom
annihilates him I think he should be a a
minus 350 favorite if you had a 12we
camp on a two-e camp I think Tom still
has the skill set and the fight IQ to
dismantle Sergey I think Sergey you know
he has obviously The Knockout streak and
he has all the power in the world I
don't think that's enough with just his
skill set to get done against a guy like
Tom asol I think Tom aspinal is the best
heavyweight the UFC has to offer I think
he proves that uh in Mass Square Garden
and I think he wins uh I would take if
this is if I'm using DraftKings I'm
taking Tom asol under five rounds he
gets a finish with a TKO or submission I
think he survives those early rounds
he's too quick he's too witty uh his
fight IQ is too high to get caught in
exchange with Serge I think he fished
his under five so either way it's a good
thing it's a bad thing that the UFC has
the resources and they're the only
League that can fill in these huge super
fights when one falls out I love that
the downside is we're not getting the
best of the best when you're doing these
short notice fights all good we still
got a
card other thing is is the Jon Jones
tearing his PEC and steep a they were
going to retire anyway why isn't this a
vacant belt this makes no freaking sense
this should just be for the heavyweight
title of the world enjoy the
fights